alright John Perry here welcome back to
what's it Wednesday good work on last
week's skull we had a lot of people ran
out of the gate that guessed that this
was some sort of an ancient whale and
you were correct this this is an ancient
whale a lot of you guessed a mule asinus
that was incorrect a lot of you guessed
wrote asinus that was also incorrect but
extremely close this is Maya Cetus the
first person to get that right was
technically Jordan Culver but he and I
worked together on an animation that
included Maya cedis in it it's skeleton
so I don't know if I can really count
him as the winner so I'm going to have
to give Cody Silver's the first-place
prize which by the way is nothing it's
just being right on the Internet
Cody Silver's you were the first person
according to my count that got this
right that guessed Maya Cetus or sorry I
shouldn't say guessed that identified
this skull as Maya Cetus now this of
course is a reconstruction the actual
skull is shown here well actually this
is the female the the model that we were
looking at was a model of the male that
was found or we think it's a male but
it's really funny whenever I show this
to anybody
especially like high school kids when
I'm doing a presentation they'll say oh
my gosh it's a it's a crocodile that's
not a whale and it does kind of look
like that I can see it's got that kind
of toothy crocodile smile but that's
because it doesn't have any skin on it
you know alive this what have had cheeks
it would have had you know lips hiding
it's its teeth and so on and it would be
very obvious that this is a mammal and
today's guest I'm really excited about
today's guest for many reasons I mean
it's just cool look at it look how
awesome this thing is but one of the
really cool things about this specimen
is that it has a jaw bone that is very
similar to the jawbone of a crocodile
the mandible of a crocodile because this
is a bird spoiler alert this is a bird
and birds and crocodiles are very
closely related
birds crocodiles dinosaurs and if we
look at the jaw you know well let me
actually show you a mammal to compare it
to you real quick let me pull out the
Bobcat again he's been
I kind of go-to for comparative anatomy
if you look at the jawbone of a mammal
as mentioned last time it's got this
structure right here called the
mandibular condyle a condyle is just any
rounded bone that fits into a hole on
another bone and this is very different
than the jawbone of a bird this look the
jaw bone of the bird instead of having a
condyle it's got a little groove there
that the skull actually sits on top of
so very very different in anatomy
between mammals and other critters
reptiles dinosaurs birds I guess you
know technically in cladistics birds are
dinosaurs but the really neat thing
about the fossil record is that you can
actually watch mammals evolve in the
fossil record and you can watch their
special jaw joint form mammals started
out as these reptile like amniotes
and slowly became more mammal like as
time went on anyway
this thing
is beautiful look at that this guy has
really good
cranial Kinesis as well remember we
looked at that on the red-tailed hawk
where the top part of the face actually
bends there's flexible bones up here
this guy's too dried out for me to bend
it for you to show you how it works
you'll have to go back and watch the
red-tailed hawk video if you had not
seen that to watch how cranial Kinesis
works but basically the bottom jaw
articulates on a joint like you would
expect and the top jaw articulates on a
bit of flexible bone up here and when
the bird was a lie that was very oily
and more flexible and it can bend the
front of its face up and down quite a
bit when it's alive and that gives it
very delicate movement of the jaw of the
face it can can do a lot with its beak
this is important for birds
you know those extra maneuverability
because they've they've really lost
their hands birds do have three fingers
in their wings but two of them are fused
together and the one that's loose is
covered in alula feathers so their hands
are pretty much good for nothing
well aside from flying and so yeah
they've they've learned to use their
feet quite well as hands and they also
have this amazing maneuverability of the
beak really cool critter this thing has
a big big huge brain case not the
biggest compared to the rest of the
skull for a bird you know some of the
corvids have slightly bigger brain cases
in comparison but this this animal is
smart it's highly social much smarter
than people typically give them credit
for this is a really cool animal I love
these guys I actually get to work with
them at the Wildlife Center where I
volunteer you know live ones and ah man
they are so cool this skull by the way
comes from should't Timoney Wildlife
Center lent out to me they're very kind
so yeah what do you think it is
what's it Wednesday what could this
fascinating beast be let me know what
you think in the comments section Morgan
you step up step up no
step up Oh bird we look up bird huh
you